tu es politiques ce matin c'est annie
genevard bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député du doubs vice
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
président du conseil national des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale dont jean fabrice vce à
vaudreuil dorion
bonjour alors que je vais manger les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
que vous connaissez bien les jeunes
parce c'est vraiment vos journaux on
commence en parlant de sécurité et cette
mobilisation des policiers qui aura lieu
devant l'assemblée nationale en début
d'après midi est ce que vous serez
présente à ces mobilisations
je serai présente je serai présente avec
mes collègues parlementaires les
républicains parce que je crois
essentiel de montrer à la police aux
forces de sécurité en général que nous
sommes à leurs côtés
du reste c'est quelque chose qui courent
devant l'opinion publique depuis un
moment après la mort du policier m'a
sont des personnes de ma circonscription
honte écrit en disant il faut faire
quelque chose il faut manifester notre
soutien aux policiers parce que les
français sentent bien confusément que il
y à là pilier notre état républicain qui
qui est l'objet de violences répétées de
plus en plus graves par des individus de
plus en plus
jeune donc il y une menace majeure qui
qu'il faut dont il faut mesurer toutes
toute l'ampleur et toutes les
conséquences possibles et je crois utile
de dire ou policier oui
les élus sont à vos côtés pour vous
soutenir dans les épreuves qui sont les
vôtres et il représente l'état l'état
doit les protéger
ce avons fait un point commun avec
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
qui sera lui aussi présent ça vaut
sûrement que le ministre de l'intérieur
manifeste sous les fenêtres de
l'assemblée nationale coûter plus grand
chose ne me surprend de ceux du
gouvernement donc là on a une situation
assez baroque c'est à dire que des
policiers manifestent pour revendiquer
un certain nombre de choses et celui
auquel ils s'adressent sera pas remis au
milieu d'eux donc moi je pense que le
rôle d'un ministre n'est pas de déplorer
une situation avec avec les manifestants
il est de remédier au problème
est-ce que c'est pas aussi son rôle de
les soutenir vous dites vous même c'est
important oui mais challes police et
chacun d'y échapper un succès soit aussi
normal qu'ils font soutien des policiers
s'est il se présente comme le premier
flic de france il le dit souvent mais en
réalité il est ministre il est en
responsabilité il tend charge
vous savez que le bout de la sécurité
qui a été relancée boycotté par une
partie des policiers
ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même un
climat qui n'est pas totalement empreint
de confiance
aujourd'hui est donc là pourquoi
pourquoi ni pourquoi il est là gérald
amendements seront ses pairs je pense
qu'il ne veut pas laisser
s'installer l'idée qu' il serait l'objet
de revendication de protestation de la
part des policiers
je pense qu'il veut se prémunir de cela
je crois
de façon générale que le pouvoir a
compris que la question de la sécurité
qui est un sujet qui a été négligé par
le pouvoir depuis 2007 est devenue
prépondérante pour les français il n'y a
pas une semaine qui se déroule qui se
passe sans que nous voyons la télévision
des images terribles de policiers pris
pour cibles que nous n'entendions des
faits divers abominable mettant aux
prises dix ans des jeunes de plus en
plus jeunes avec souvent des coups
mortels et encore hier encore hier alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut donc gérer la
question de la sécurité les devenu
majeur est donc là darmanin sent bien
que il doit pas être absents de ce
théâtre d'opérations que c'est bien
qu'ils s'en rend pas oui mais chacun à
sa place
est ce que le rôle des miss et de
manifester les manifestants je ne crois
pas c'est d'apporter des vraies réponses
aujourd'hui on sait que notamment en
matière pénale
le compte n'y est pas alors il a apporté
des réponses jean castex il ya la
semaine dernière il a dit qu'il y aurait
une augmentation des peines pour les
agresseurs de forces de l'ordre
notamment est ce que il ya quand même
pas des réponses il ya aussi des
augmentations d'effectifs une
augmentation du budget de la sécurité
une augmentation du budget de la justice
est ce que les réponses ne sont pas là
de la part du kurde où ça a été redit
que tout ça est tardif parce qu'en
réalité depuis trois ans les coups et
blessures ont augmenté de plus de 20%
le problème n'a pas sur une dans les
dernières semaines
le problème existe déjà depuis de
nombreuses années ce processus là qui
atteint des proportions invraisemblables
il a commencé depuis déjà plusieurs
années le pouvoir ne s'en saisit que
trop tardivement
vous savez il faudra plusieurs années
pour restaurer l'autorité de l'état
qu'on a laissé trop longtemps s'abîmer
vous évoquer l'aspect judiciaire est ce
que cette la question se pose depuis
plusieurs semaines est ce que cette
manifestation c'est une manifestation de
l'institution policière contre celle de
la justice alors il ya un problème de la
chaîne pénale tout le monde le sait il
est il suffit d'interroger des policiers
ou des gendarmes
il faut pas bien longtemps pour qu ils
ne vous disent qu'ils arrêtent et soit
la réponse n'est pas là soit elle est
trop tardive
en tout cas d'où ce trop demander peine
annoncée trop de peines non exécutées
cent mille peines non exécutées dans
d'autres pays
c'est une défaite majeure de la justice
hier nous avons commencé l'examen de
projets de loi restauration de la
confiance dans la justice dans les
discussions générales il a été rappelé
que la durée moyenne d'audiencement pour
des affaires criminelles et de 40 mois
plus de trois ans
ayez donc on a un souci manifestement
avec une justice qui qui ne suit pas
toujours et qui n'offre pas toujours les
réponses que nous attendons l as que le
texte que vous examinez en ce moment
même il répond ah ça correctement selon
plus écoutée l'avenir le dira toujours
est il que entre le moment où le texte
démarre son examen
au parlement et le moment où il sera
adopté mise en oeuvre on sera à la fin
du quinquennat
donc ça veut dire que ce problème il
aura été laissées en jachère pendant
quasiment toute la durée du quinquennat
et l'arrivée tardive de du garde des
sceaux
la mise en oeuvre trop tardive des
mesures de durcissement et puis des
questions qui sont évacuées parce
qu'elles viennent de l'opposition la
question des peines planchers que nous
réclamons pour les auteurs d'actes de
violence contre les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique sont rayés d'un
trait de plume par le garde des sceaux
qui dit ça ne marche pas ça me rappelle
lyonnais a ajouté m il vous a dit aux
questions d'actualité il a dit c'est un
placebo les peines plancher c'est un
fiasco les peines prononcées sont
inférieures avec les peines plancher
alors les villes attestions dépasser
enfin ces points sont réellement
contester ce que je veux dire c'est que
il faut la certitude de la peine il faut
que les auteurs de violences sache que
la peine est certaine qu'elle sera
exécutée qu'elle sera rapidement exécuté
parce que sinon eh bien nous assistons à
un délitement de l'autorité publique qui
jette un climat de 2,2 d'inquiétude dans
la population à un niveau que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis très longtemps
et dont continuent à les réclamer ces
peines plancher nous nous continuerons à
réclamer des peines planchers
et tous les arguments qui nous sont
opposés par exemple la question de la
constitutionnalité
je regrette le conseil constitutionnel
avait validé les peines plancher pour
les récidivistes
donc il y a un chemin
et je trouve de façon générale que ce
pouvoir est sourd aux propositions de
l'opposition il dit en même temps il n'y
a pas de proposition et en même temps
nous ne voulons pas de vos propositions
ce n'est pas de la bonne façon de faire
la politique et je le regrette
profondément parce que c'est notre pays
qui en souffre vous avez un désaccord
sur les peines plancher avec eric dupond
moretti
mais sinon dans l'ensemble est ce que
eric dupond-moretti selon vous s'est
emparé du sujet des sujets qui vous
préoccupent qui préoccupent les français
est il un bon ministre de la justice
je trouve que il a de la voix
blanc l'avocat perce sous le ministre en
permanence il est physiquement
vocalement présent maintenant ce qu'on
attend d'un ministre et d'un garde des
sceaux c'est les réponses précises
concrètes aux situation que connaissent
les français donc c'est à l'aune de ces
propositions de l'efficacité de ces
propositions
tout n'est pas à jeter dans la
réforme qu'il propose il faut pas être
caricatural il ya des choses
intéressantes notamment sur le secret de
l'instruction
je suis un peu plus dubitatif sur les
audiences film est bon ça je ne sais pas
vraiment ce que ça apportera de mon
temps l'une des choses que tout le monde
va en retenir de cette langue oui mais
comme toujours est ce que c'est pas de
l'ordre du un peu du gadget ce qu'on
attend c'est véritablement tout ce qui
touche aux
à l'efficacité de la justice à sa
rapidité à sa certitude ça c'est le
noyau dur d'une réforme de la justice
utile et du coup quelle sera votre
position sur ce texte
mais écoutez il démarre on démarre
l'examen donc nos collègues spécialistes
de ces questions suivre cela de près on
verra aussi comment sont reçus nos
propositions
comme je vous le disais ya pas d'à
priori négative ou zen pas compte 3 mai
réformer la justice si ça va dans le bon
sens évidemment déjà prêtes à voter pour
tout ça nous paraît encore un peu
frileux mais bon à voir on va parler du
déconfinement notre actualité fabrice
est oui alors c'est le jour j est
attendu chez voûte les est ce que tout
le monde va rouvrir est ce que vous
sentez les entreprises prêtes à
s'investir dans cette réouverture
partielle
écoutez je pense que beaucoup seront
soulagés de pouvoir ouvrir parce que
sept mois de fermeture c'est bien long
c'est inédit
néanmoins les difficultés sont là il ya
des établissements sans terrasse il ya
des établissements très affaibli est
évidemment aidé selon yves pardon
suffisamment aidé et soutenu à l'horizon
et t&d mais comme toujours il ya des
trous dans la raquette il ya des jeunes
qui venaient de créer leur entreprise
qui n'avait pas de chiffre d'affaires de
référence qui n'ont pas pu être aidés il
ya des entreprises dont la trésorerie
est exemple et qui n'ont plus les moyens
d'investir ne serait ce que dans
l'aménagement d'une terrasse
il ya des difficultés de recrutement de
personnel c'est incroyable mais c'est
ainsi beaucoup d'entreprises et
notamment dans le domaine de la
restauration nous disent on peine à
recruter parce qu'ils ont perdu du
personnel entre temps parce que faut
remettre la france au travail et que
c'est pas facile
en tout état de cause évidemment je me
réjouis la réouverture des
établissements et des commerces
pour ce qui concerne les restaurants et
les cafés et ça fait longtemps que les
républicains nous préconisions que des
mesures adaptées sanitaires
apt et permettre la réouverture donc
voilà ça finit par arriver
espérant qu' il n'y aura pas trop de
morts économique sur le bord du chemin
un mot sur le pass annie terre puisqu'il
a été voté par les sénateurs qui l'ont
un peu renforcé qui l'encadré du coup le
pass sanitaires il sera valable pour les
grands rassemblements et pas pour les
actes du quotidien
est-ce que ça ça vous semble bon
compromis ou est-ce que c'est risqué sur
le plan sanitaire
dans cette période où l'épidémie est
encore là quand même nous nous
considérons que tant que la population
ne sera pas vaccinés à peu près à 60 %
on peut pas imposer le pass annie terre
partout parce que ça voudrait dire que
des gens qui voudraient être vaccinés
qui n'ont pas pu l'être se voit imposer
une limitation encore accrue de leur
liberté de circulation dont marguerite
elle s'acquiert aussi montrer qu'on a
été guéri ou présentent des aspects
sierre s'est pas il n'y a pas que le
vaccin
oui mais enfin il faut aussi traiter les
citoyens de façon égale et équitable
deuxièmement le donc ça c'est le premier
point sur le pass sanitaires nous nous
avions essayé à l'assemblée nationale
d'introduire la notion de densité cyr
mille personnes au stade de france pas
pareil que 1000 personnes dans une salle
de spectacle il faut tenir compte aussi
de la densité de la population et ahmad
jaune du tour mais pardon n'y a pas de
jauge du tout dans la loi ça vous paraît
pas pas assez précis pas assez clair il
ya une jauge de mille 1000 personnes
n'est pas inscrite qui n'est pas
inscrite précisément écouter en tout cas
là le bon sens voudrait que l'on tienne
compte de la densité si ces danses c'est
plus risqué que ça ne l'est pas et puis
la troisième chose
le pass and i ter n'a pas mis fin aux
couvre-feux donc cette année état
d'urgence qui se prolonge sans dire son
nom
mais voilà vous êtes d'accord avec les
sénateurs qui prolonge l'état d'urgence
actuelle jusqu'au 30 juin pour que ça
colle bien à la période de l'avenir du
couvre vous et nous y étions favorables
on va parler des républicains de l'autre
partie est
et de ce qu'on peut appeler le
feuilleton maintenant dans la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur avec un
nouvel épisode hier et ce communiqué de
christian jacob qui dit souhaiter la
victoire de renaud muselier pour
empêcher le basculement de la région
rassemblement national il souhaite sa
victoire mais il n'emploie jamais le mot
soutien à renaud muselier est ce que ça
veut dire que désormais pour vous nos
muselier c'est le candidat du front
républicain et plus le candidat des
républicains n'ont donc j'ai lié
il a dit d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises
appartient à notre famille politique
dans cette affaire
nous avons eu hier aux conseillers
stratégie des républicains le souci
premier de clore cette séquence qui est
terrible un terme d'image mais dont nous
sommes des victimes qu'est ce que vous
voulez les hommes sont les hommes et
leur décision même si on nous les
jugeons mauvaise quand elles sont prises
on ne peut pas toujours les amplis et
qui est le coupable alors si vous êtes
donc renaud muselier a pris une décision
dont le nom lui avons dit à multiples
reprises qu'elle était une décision
mauvaise et pour lui et pour sa famille
politique pour lui parce qu'il n'a pas
fallu attendre longtemps pour qu on voit
les sondages baissé en ce qui le
concerne et augmenté en ce qui concerne
mariani donc c'était une décision qui
allait le mettre davantage en péril qui
allaient l'exposé et qui à exposer
inutilement sa famille politique donc
une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut faire
preuve de responsabilité d'abord il
fallait arrêter ce feuilleton soutien
retrait du soutien puis à nouveau
soutien complet plein soutien les puits
et on pouvait pas continuer à la voilà
donc on en clos la séquence est pour ça
que le mot soutien n'y est pas parce que
dès lors qu'il était employé ça allait
relancer la machine mais nous sommes
très clairs entre mariani et muselier il
n'y a pas
d'hésitation à avoir évidemment nous
souhaitons la victoire de renaud
muselier et même ceux qui hier ont voté
contre
je rappelle quand même que trois membres
du conseil stratégique sur quatre ont
voté en faveur de la résolution que nous
avons prises
et même ceux qui ont voté contre ont dit
clairement qu'ils souhaitaient la
victoire de renaud muselier
on ne peut pas souhaiter la victoire du
rassemblement national en paca ce que
nous faisons c'est clair chez tout le
monde y en a il y en a dans votre parti
qui disent qu'ils voteront blanc écoutez
et pas des moins de françois-xavier
bellamy par exemple oui mais ce qui est
ce qui est ressorti hier y compris je
vous le dit chez eric ciotti c'est que
nous souhaitions que renaud muselier
l'emportent sur son adversaire au
rassemblement actionnaires s'est dit ça
eric ciotti l'a dit clairement
eric ciotti l'a dit clairement on ne se
trompe pas d'adversaire
nous savons où nous sommes maintenant on
ne peut pas valider la position qu'a
prise renaud muselier à l'égard de la
république en marche et surtout nous
voulons dénoncé les basses manoeuvres
ourdies par le président de la
république lui-même parce que cette
stratégie elle a été décidée à l'elysée
pourquoi pour fracturer la droite pour
affaiblir à droite pour être seul face
au rassemblement national
ces manoeuvres là qui nuisent à la
démocratie qui nuisent aux à la liberté
de choix des français sont indignes
indigne d'un président de la république
est irresponsable parce que à ce petit
jeu là un jour peut-être ce que l'on
redoute se produire à lui jamais à ce
propos puisque la question en fait pour
paca c'est de savoir comment les
républicains comme la république en
marche fonds pour éviter d'élection du
rassemblement national la question on
risque de se poser aussi quand on
regarde un petit peu les tendances and
opinions dans votre région
en bourgogne franche comté qui est
l'autre région qui peut basculer
qui peut tomber dans l'escarcelle du
front national qu'est ce qui se passe
comment vous l'expliquez qui viennent
des régions comme ça qu'ils soient à
portée de main du rassemblement national
je pense que fin je peux me tromper
parce que la science politique n'est pas
toujours une science exacte d'ailleurs
on vient d'en avoir la démonstration
mais il me semble que bourgogne franche
comté est moins exposée à ce risque que
ne l'est par exemple paca on a en
bourgogne et surtout en franche comté
une région très industrielle mais on
sait que
certaines catégories sociologiques sont
plus je dirais plus perméable aux thèses
du rassemblement national les régions
ouvrière notamment est ce que c'est un
élément d'explication on a un candidat
du rassemblement national qui est assez
grande gueule si vous me permettez
l'expression qu'on entend beaucoup
est-ce que ça ça peut laisser à penser
qu'il l'emporterait en même temps c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas toujours très
contrôlée non plus donc je suis un peu
plus j'ai un peu plus réservé sur cette
analyse il est clair que la gauche qui a
gagné c'est région grâce au maintien du
front national je tiens à le rappeler
quand même la victoire de la gauche en
franche-comté pub qui elle n'a été
possible et dans la grande région ci que
parce que le front national s'est
toujours maintenu au second tour sir
mettre son bulletin dans le
pour le rassemblement national front
national s'était assuré la victoire de
la gauche est ce qui se passe et c'est
une différence récurrents par est tenue
par la droite et moi la bourgogne
franche comté pour la gauche donc pardon
nous verrons nous verrons ce qu'il en
est en tout cas avec gilles platret nous
avons un candidat qui s'est clairement
emparée des questions régaliennes qui
sont un peu le fonds de commerce du
rassemblement national
c'est quelqu'un qui est très ferme sur
les questions de sécurité d'immigration
de cohésion nationale de lutte contre le
communautarisme qui sont des thèmes que
le rassemblement national dont il n'est
pas le propriétaire la droite et sur ces
questions-là a fait énormément de
propositions donc j'ai le platonisme ne
sont pas des thèmes sur lesquels les
régions des compétences est ce que du
coup on n'est pas à la sécurité
nationale que régionale si la sécurité
dans les lycées dans les transports
publics c'est une compétence régionale
mais ça ça
donc et puis de toute façon il ya une
dimension nationale dans ces régionales
se dire que même sur des questions qui
ne relèvent pas des compétences des
régions les candidats aux régionales
sont interrogés jeu sur gilles platret
puisque j'en parlais drilles a fait le
choix de s'allier avec debout la france
le parti de nicolas dupont aignan ça ça
ne vous a pas gêné ça ne nous a pas posé
de problème ce qui ne m'a pas gêné c'est
que gilles platret face à large
rassemblement avec debout la france mais
avec lui des avec le nouveau centre avec
les chasseurs avec les indépendants avec
les écologistes d'antoine waechter
c'est une logique de rassemblement moi
j'aime mieux que kylie palais jusqu'à
debout la france les sites le centre
debout la france aux dernières élections
régionales j'aime mieux qu'il vienne
qu'il se porte sur notre candidat plutôt
plutôt qu'ailleurs
je fais une distinction entre debout la
france et le rassemblement national
je pense qu'on a instruit un peu un
procès en sorcellerie à gilles platret
parce que les personnes qu'il a choisis
sont des personnes parfaitement
républicaine des élus qui ont reçu
l'onction du suffrage universel donc il
faut pas tout mélanger
mais en tant que présidente du conseil
national des républicains vous pensez
qu'il est c'est le moment de
retravailler avec nicolas dupont aignan
écoutez on retravaille pas avec dupont
aignan on a choisi dans une logique de
rassemblement des candidats qui ont
adhéré à ce mouvement
mais ça veut dire qu'au plan national y
aura pas de discussion cela dupont
aignan écoute qu'il ne souhaitait pas je
n'en sais rien nous n'en sommes pas là
pour l'instant chaque choix de livres
par dom ne l'excluait pas en son temps
il a été avec nous dupont aignan mais
vous souhaitez qu'il arrive cet égard et
du côté du front national
il en est revenu et si on stigmatise en
permanence ce qui ont été ou qui seront
peut-être ou qui voudraient peut-être
l'être il faut un moment une logique de
l'as l'heure du repentir leur union
mentir je pense que du nicolas dupont
aignan est debout la france c'est un
mouvement patriote le patriotisme n'est
pas quelque chose d' insulte en question
sur laurent wauquiez bah oui parce qu'il
ya des régionales lui aussi en auvergne
et rhône alpes
laurent wauquiez que vous avez soutenu
quand il était président de votre votre
parti est accusé par un des anciens
préfet de la haute loire qui est
aujourd'hui en retraite d'avoir attisé
le conflit des gilet jaune dans un livre
là qui sort ces dernières ces dernières
heures
vous y croyez je trouve incroyable quand
même maintenant si un préfet
parce que certes il n'est peut-être plus
soumis au devoir de réserve
m'enfin c'est assez inédit qu'un
serviteur de l'état se permettent de
juger un élu au moment des élections
régionales de surcroît je trouve que
c'est un manquement grave à l'éthique
personnelle et l'éthique qui fut
l'éthique professionnelle de ce préfet
donc et puis sur le fond je pense que
lorsque le mouvement des légions n'a
surgi rappelez-vous dans sa première
configuration c'était des retraités des
petits chefs d'entreprises des mères de
famille c'était des défilés bon enfant
moi je me souviens à pontarlier
il y avait eu vraiment une manifestation
des plus pacifiques et que les élus
étaient à leurs côtés à ce moment là
n'avaient rien à des sens c'étaient les
classes moyennes de la france celle
qu'on a trop longtemps oublié donc
franchement il n'y avait rien
d'insultant d'indécente d'anti
république à être à leurs côtés ensuite
le mouvement s'est durci et là nous
avons pris nos distances et je crois que
c'est exactement ce qu'a fait laurent
wauquiez dans ces régions et on lui
cherche on lui fait un mauvais procès au
moment des régionales je trouve ça
indécent
dernière question sur laurent wauquiez
est ce que ce serait le bon candidat
pour vous de votre famille politique à
la mine incidentielle écouter dans cette
dans cette question des candidatures à
la présidentielle nous avons au fond la
chance à droite d'avoir plusieurs
candidats de très bons et de très bonne
qualité qui seraient susceptibles de
remplir la fonction
peut-être est-ce aussi d'autres
problèmes parce que nous en avons plus
plus qu'un seul mais laurent vous qui
est valérie pécresse xavier bertrand
mais vous les mettez tous ces plans
aucun a votre préférence sont
manifestement des gens de qualité qui
ont une expérience et qui pourrait tout
à fait remplir la fonction je me suis
interdite de d'exprimer une quelconque
préférence à ce stade parce que je pense
que le temps des écuries a vécu nous en
avons éprouvé tous les désordres lors
des dernières élections présidentielles
je me refuse moi je me rangerai jeu
participerez naturellement au débat sur
le choix du candidat ou de la candidate
mais à ce stade
à ce stade je me refuse à tous à tout
autre commentaire
merci beaucoup merci annie jeanne l'art
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
regarde la une de l'est républicain
c'est benzema à la une de l'est
républicain fabrice oui parce que ça va
au-delà du sport autour de retours de
benzema
un je pense que ça intéresse au delà des
sportifs merci fabrice mercier ni jeanne
mas
[Musique]